[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit google
hause und claus kleber
guten abend als wäre plötzlich neue
erkenntnis vom himmel gefallen haben
sich die regierungsparteien heute gerade
noch vor der selbst gesetzten deadline
offenbar auf neue grenzkontrollen
geeinigt auslands rückkehrer müssen ab
sonntag einen negativen test vorweisen
es sei denn er oder sie wären bestätigt
schriftlich durchgeimpft oder von corona
genießen beim corona drahtseilakt
zwischen nicht leichtsinnig werden aber
den leuten besser auch nicht zu viel
zumuten liegt im moment mal wieder die
gruppe vorsicht vorne zu der zum
beispiel der kandidaten laschet nicht so
gehörte der trend der zahlen spricht
dafür
aktuell meldet das robert-koch-institut
3142 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 1252 mehr als letzten
donnerstag und 21 todesfälle kamen dazu
die sieben tage incidents steigt weiter
auf 16
in dieser lage duldet markus söder
selbst ernannte anführer des teams
vorsicht unter den ministerpräsidenten
einen ausgewiesenen impfskepsis im
kabinett nicht irgendwo sondern als
stellvertretenden regierungschef bereits
volle kombi finden stefan leifert und
alexander pohl
es ist der 29 juni das bayerische
kabinett hat gerade getagt als klar wird
markus söder und hubert aiwanger die
beiden alphatiere der bayerischen
regierungskoalition haben ein problem
vielleicht sagst du selber was dazu
warum du einfach nicht impfen lassen
willst entscheidung ob sich jemand
impfen lässt oder nicht ist eine
persönliche entscheidung die nehme ich
auch für mich in anspruch und die laute
geben dass ich mich bisher nicht dazu
entscheiden konnte mich impfen zu lassen
ein impf zweifler in den eigenen
regierungsreihen sein stellvertreter
dazu das kann markus söder im
beginnenden wahlkampf nicht gebrauchen
söder der sich und bayern als
spitzenreiter in der korona bekämpfung
preist obwohl die impfzahlen nur
durchschnittlich sind eher der dieses
image immer wieder nutzt um dem
kanzlerkandidaten der union zu zeigen
krise kann und wer nicht in dieser lage
also versetzt hubert aiwanger der chef
der freien wähler dem selbsternannten
kanzlerkandidaten herzen ein tritt vors
schienbein
in einem interview mit dem
deutschlandfunk treibt er seine
impfskepsis auf die spitze es wird auch
der gegenstände nicht darum herumkommen
sich bei gewissen anlässen zu testen ist
glaube ich es besser als jetzt die jagd
auf zu nehmen auf diejenigen die noch
nicht kennst sind man muss auch kein
geheimnis draus machen aus man in seinem
persönlichen umfeld immer mehr von hört
die massive impfnebenwirkungen
auszuhalten haben da bleibt einem schon
das eine oder andere mal die spucke weg
die zweifel die aiwanger sieht sollen
ihm und seiner partei im september
stimmen der politischen ränder
einbringen genug für den einzug in den
bundestag und söder
er lässt aiwanger spiel mit dem feuer zu
sonst bliebe ihm nur die regierung in
bayern platzen zu lassen
ein gedanke der einem wie söder nicht
ferner liegen könnte und doch muss er
irgendwie reagieren
der ärger in der csu über den kleinen
koalitionspartner wird spürbar lauter
der druck auf söder damit größer wenn
jemand sagt ich möchte mir dieses grund
die grundfreiheiten mich nicht impfen zu
lassen habe ich respekt davor wenn man
aber das impfen generell infrage
gestellt auch mit argumenten die mehr an
schamanen erinnern oder an annan
verschwörungstheoretiker denn an eine
wissenschaftlich begründete diskussion
dann wird's schwierig schwierig auch für
ihn denn sollte albaners im skepsis
verfangen könnte das am ende auch die
bilanz von söders kampf gegen das virus
massiv beeinträchtigen
da werden mal eben schamanen in die
deutsche politische diskussion
eingeführt
zu ganz anderen soll ein gespenst geht
um nicht nur in europa in der gesamten
kapitalistisch marktwirtschaftlich
organisierten welt das gespenst der
inflation von vielen lang erwartet
trotzdem irgendwie überraschend ist es
jetzt wieder da platzt heute in den 0
zinslandschaft deutschland mit 3,8
prozent inflationsrate für diesen juli
das ist die höchste zahl seit fast 30
jahren
manche menschen vom fach finden jetzt
alle möglichen erklärungen dafür weshalb
das sondereffekte seien und alles bald
wieder mal normal werden müsse aber es
bleibt doch ein ungutes gefühl inflation
geld entwerten könnte der notausgang
sein wenn staaten sich bis über die
ohren verschuldet hatten wie jetzt ein
weg allerdings auf kosten risikoscheu
aber stefan schlösser auf den spuren des
gespenstes hier in bad vilbel entsteht
eine neue lagerhalle tausende tonnen
material wurden schon für die
bodenplatte verbaut jetzt folgt der
aufbau der halle aus starten seit der
ausschreibung des auftrags haben sich
die preise für baustoffe aller art
deutlich verteuert teilweise haben sie
sich mehr als verdoppelt die baukosten
haben sich verheerend entwickelt massiv
gestiegen beim stahl von 650 euro auf
1150 euro
beim holz der kubikmeter von 155 euro
auf 310 das sind fast mehr als 100
prozent dämmstoffe 30 prozent und es ist
im moment kein ende in sicht
würde man die halle noch einmal bauen
sie würde jetzt mindestens 30 prozent
mehr kosten
auch die preise für sprit und heizöl
steigen weiter das merken autofahrer an
der tankstelle schon wird einführung der
co2 steuer zu jahresbeginn sind die
energiekosten angestiegen mit der
weltweiten konjunkturellen erholung
zieht die nachfrage nach erdöl weiter an
auch manche dienstleistung es teurer
geworden ob friseure oder gaststätten
viele haben mit wiedereröffnung nach dem
schotter und die preise erhöht als
drittes hatten wir ja die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer die am ersten juli
letztes jahr angefangen hat und da macht
sich jetzt in der gegenbewegung eben am
ersten juli diesen jahres die
rückführung zu den ursprünglichen raten
bemerkbar
das alles schlägt sich in der
inflationsrate nieder nachdem das
preisniveau längere zeit sogar gesunken
war steigt es seit jahresbeginn rasant
an auf aktuell 3,8 prozent im juli so
hoch wie seit 1993 nicht mehr
und das könnte noch ein paar monate so
weitergehen die ersten gewerkschafter
fordern
ja schon jetzt ein sattes lohnplus für
die nächste verhandlungsrunde
wir haben den punkt das nun verträge ja
für viele jahre abgeschlossen werden
und da halte ich es ja schon für
relevant das maß gehalten wird so dass
eben wir keine lohn preis spirale
bekommen die dann überhaupt erst
inflation in gang setzen könnte
im kommenden jahr erwarten ohnehin fast
alle ökonomen dass sich die
inflationsrate wieder normalisiert auf
werte von unter zwei prozent
die europäische zentralbank sieht es
genauso deshalb machen die notenbanker
auch keine anstalten von ihrer lockeren
geldpolitik mit nullzinsen loszulassen
doppelt schlecht für alle die ihr geld
auf dem konto liegen lassen oder ins
sparschwein stecken zinsen gibt es
ohnehin nicht mehr
und jetzt kann man sich für sein geld
auch noch weniger tage
ich muss schon sagen für einen tag an
dem fast vier prozent inflation
verkündet werden geht die kurs kurve
hinter ihnen da ziemlich fröhlich nach
oben
ja die base nimmt's gelassen weil viele
glauben das geht schon vorbei und
einiges spricht ja auch dafür die
mehrwertsteuer anhebung dieses jahr hat
die preise ja automatisch steigen lassen
ebenso corona bedingte lieferengpässe
jahr die tatsache dass die aktuellen
preise mit denen im corona jahr
verglichen werden als die pandemie
bedingt ja besonders niedrig waren
das verzerrt natürlich bis zum
jahresende könnte die inflationsrate
noch anziehen laut bundesbank vielleicht
sogar auf nahezu fünf prozent nächstes
jahr aber dürfte sich die lage dann
wieder entspannen
dabei war doch anfang des jahres noch
angst vor deflation das heißt
wegbrechende preise nach unten
die hätten absoluten killer bedeuten
können weil die leute dann nichts mehr
kaufen weil sie auf noch niedrigere
preise hoffen
das ist jedenfalls erst mal vorbei ja
vermutlich weil es auch argumente für
längerfristig höhere preise gibt also
nicht so drastisch wie aktuell aber
dennoch höher kräftigen lohnforderungen
zum beispiel die gab es ja heute schon
von verdi außerdem verfügen die
niedrigen zinsen zu hohen staatsausgaben
wie zum beispiel gewaltige infrastruktur
infrastrukturprojekte und die effekte
der klimapolitik weil unternehmen und
privatleute aufgrund strengerer auflagen
in modernisierungen investieren all das
führt zu höherer nachfrage und
irgendwann zu vermutlich auch höheren
preisen
wir werden sehen dankeschön valerie und
die nachrichten von gundula beginnen mit
erfreulichen zahlen
die zahl der arbeitslosen in deutschland
ist erstmals seit 15 jahren in einem
juli gesunken
niedrigere infektionszahlen ermöglichten
wieder mehr beschäftigung so die
bundesagentur für arbeit derzeit sind
zwei millionen 590.000 menschen
arbeitslos gemeldet 24.000 weniger als
im juni
die quote sinkt leicht auf 5,6 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahr sind 320.000
menschen weniger auf jobsuche
zwei tage nach der verheerenden
explosion in einem leverkusener
chemiepark sind drei weitere menschen
tot in den trümmern gefunden worden
damit erhöht sich die zahl der
bestätigten todesopfer auf fünf zwei
menschen werden weiterhin vermisst
ermittler konnten erstmals den
explosionsort begutachten die
unglücksursache ist nach wie vor unklar
ebenso die frage ob durch die rauchwolke
schadstoffe in die umgebung getragen
wurden
in rom hat sich die regierung von
ministerpräsident draghi nach
wochenlangem streit auf eine zentrale
justizreform verständigt dabei geht es
vor allem um verjährungsfristen die in
italien bislang sehr lang waren eine
reform der justiz der das parlament noch
zustimmen muss ist eines der vorhaben
die trage der eu als voraussetzung für
milliardenschwere wiederaufbauhilfen
zugesagt hatte zwei wochen nach der
flutkatastrophe in nordrhein westfalen
und in rheinland pfalz ist die situation
in den betroffenen regionen weiterhin
kritisch aufräumarbeiten
schadensregulierung müllberge und
umweltverschmutzung hilfe wird dringend
gebraucht durch spenden finanziert wurde
zb in ahrweiler vom deutschen roten
kreuz ein großer generator aufgestellt
30 haushalte werden so mit strom
versorgt von den spendengeldern werden
aber auch warm war mahlzeiten für die
flutopfer und die helfer angeboten oder
durch container zur verfügung gestellt
die spendenbereitschaft ist also
weiterhin groß allein durch die zdf
spendenaktion kamen bislang fast 60
millionen euro zusammen
die hilfe kommt an über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe spenden
konto iban de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen unter spenden zdf de und
im zf text auf seite 8 190 die
glücklicheren familien in den gebieten
der flutkatastrophe deren häuser
einigermaßen entstand geblieben sind
können schon jetzt einen neuanfang
versuchen wenn sie nicht auf staatliche
hilfen warten müssen wenn sie zu den
etwa 50 prozent der eigentümer gehören
die dort privat eine
elementarversicherung gegen
naturkatastrophen abgeschlossen haben
dann haben sie einen anspruch torge bode
ist in nordrhein westfalen in den
zerstörten gebieten der dass der stadt
schleiden unterwegs begleitet menschen
die in rascher folge von haus zu haus
schaden einschätzen und mindestens schon
mal vorläufig die vielfältigste hilfe
von allen zu teilen geld
dutzende orte termine haben
schadensregulierer die duschen und sein
team in den letzten tagen absolviert
diese hausbegehung entscheiden ist schon
nach wenigen minuten zu ende
sehr schwere leben schüttungen drin die
komplett durchtränkt sind die starken
sich schon durch und das unmittelbar
davor zusammenzubrechen
es besteht akute einsturzgefahr wir
müssen diesen teil des hauses verlassen
23 jahre hat maren rettinger in dem
denkmalgeschützten fachwerkhaus gelebt
ihre kinder sind hier groß geworden als
das wasser kam war die familie zum glück
im urlaub das haus elementar versichert
jetzt hoffen sie dass die versicherung
schnell zahlt denn maren rettinger
träumt von einem neustart
wenn ich das okay kriege da auch sehr
frei mit umgehen zu können
es ist so dass wir dann vielleicht noch
mal druck machen als familie und sagen
ach ja das ist unser eltern was wir noch
zu retten ist ungewiss vielleicht teile
des hauses doch manchmal muss guido
schlund seinen kunden den traum vom
wiederaufbau nehmen
das hochwasser wird die versicherer
milliardenkosten eine exakte summe kann
auch niemand nennen unzählige fälle sind
noch gar nicht bearbeitet
in einer andern muss man auch um geduld
bitten weil diese flut und diese menge
an schäden
das ist wirklich eine herkulesaufgabe
für jeden fall sicher der nächste termin
das wasser der olef kam am abend und sk
mit macht jürgen kampmeier hand noch ein
kurzes video drehen können dann muss er
sich selbst in sicherheit bringen
die ganze läuft voll sie müssen jetzt
kommen 15 rp jetzt zwei wochen später
ist der mann von der versicherung da und
die kunden von guido schlunz haben viele
fragen natürlich auch wieder mit den
handwerkern geht weil wir bekommen im
moment kein handwerker dann haben sie
gesehen haben draußen zum bauschutt wer
entsorgt hat mit dem geld der
versicherung kann man vieles wieder
reparieren
doch die nerven liegen auch zwei wochen
nach der katastrophe immer mal wieder
blank ohne unsere kinder und
schwiegersohn und tochter und enkelkind
noch ein ortsbesuch und es wird kein
leichter
in diesem keller ist ein mensch im
hochwasser ums leben gekommen der boden
voller schlamm der geruch von öl beißt
in der nase wir sind hier nicht die
angehörigen in trauer
trotzdem muss der mann von der
versicherung seinen job machen das ist
manchmal schwierig der arbeitgeber
bietet dann auch mal psychologische
hilfe an
das aufgrund des öls hier ein problem
besteht und dass hier ebenfalls im worst
case auch sein kann dass das gebäude
nicht zu sanieren ist und abzureißen ist
wieder schluss und seine kollegen haben
viel elend in den letzten tagen gesehen
und bis das ganze ausmaß der katastrophe
erfasst ist wird es wohl noch monate
dauern
in solchen nahaufnahmen wird wirklich
begeistert was so eine katastrophe
bedeutet das beste mittel gegen viren
angriffe in körpern wie in computern ist
eine starke abwehr eine immunreaktion
die sagt hier kommst du virus nicht
halten so was ähnliches sollte auch im
kopf funktionieren in der welt der
vorstellungen und ideen deutsche
geschichte mehr als andere hat gezeigt
wie rasend schnell sich gedanken viren
von hass und ausgrenzung in menschen und
gesellschaften einnisten und verbreiten
können
danach musste deutschland seine hoffnung
darauf setzen dass die konfrontation mit
dem grauenvollen geschehen damals wissen
bildung einen schutz gegen vorurteile
und mörderische gedanken baut das hat
tatsächlich funktioniert nicht
hundertprozentig das sind impfungen ja
auch nie aber offenheit und wissen haben
geholfen
wer aber seinen hintergrund in ländern
und kulturen hat in denen antisemitismus
gang und gäbe ist wie selbstverständlich
akzeptiert dem fehlt diese abwehr oft
jutta sonne wald berichtet dass es
möglich ist sie nachzuholen in direkter
konfrontation mit dem was damals war
diesen ausflug ins ehemalige kz
flossenbürg haben sie lange vorbereitet
die meisten dieser berufsschüler und
schülerinnen aus schwandorf darunter
viele geflüchtete haben noch nie ein
konzentrationslager gesehen geschweige
denn etwas über die gräueltaten der
nazis gehört bei diesem gedenkstätten
besuch lernen sie nicht nur etwas über
deutsche geschichte
es geht auch um antisemitismus
ausgrenzung und rassismus
warum menschen
remember heißt dieses projekt welches
sich an junge menschen mit
unterschiedlichen
herkunfts biografien wendet einige von
ihnen sind in totalitären oder
autoritären regimen aufgewachsen hier
lernen sie eine neue offenheit und
toleranz gegenüber menschen mit anderen
einstellungen werten oder religionen
unterstützt wird das projekt von der
mansour initiative für demokratie
förderung und extremismus prävention
meint prevention entscheidend die jungen
leute werden gedanklich da abgeholt wo
sie herkommen was sind die eigenen
zugänge aus deren herkunftsländer und
die anknüpfungspunkte zu nehmen
begegnungen schaffen emotionale
begegnung schaffen um eben genau diese
bilder stereotype die sie mitgebracht
haben aufzubrechen und dann neue
antworten geben zu können wie sie sich
auch dann in einem deutschland was im
pluralis was diversen möchte auch
zurechtfinden können
emotionale begegnungen schaffen um
vorurteile abzubauen
dazu gehört zum beispiel ein treffen mit
jungen jüdinnen und juden vor allem für
diejenigen aus arabischen ländern wo
israel und die juden als feindbilder
gelten ein erlebnis mit großem effekt
die jungen menschen sollen sich bei
diesem projekt über ihre eigenen
geschichten austauschen und ihre werte
bilder kritisch reflektieren um sich
beispielsweise über den nahost-konflikt
ein differenziertes bild zu machen hören
sie auch die perspektive eines
palästinensers
gibt es auch so ist ich habe die wahl
unterschiedliche die vision die juden
und die andere leute die haben zu mir
gesagt über juden das vergleichen
ziel des remember projektes ist es das
demokratische bewusstsein dieser jungen
menschen aus den unterschiedlichsten
herkunftsländern zu festigen und das
nicht nur für den moment dass die leute
die hier mitgemacht haben das sind die
breite tragen in die breite ihrer
sozialen beziehungen in ihre
freundeskreise aber auch in die breite
der gesellschaft dass sie gegen den host
einfach aufstehen und einschalten
im herbst werden diese berufsschüler und
schülerinnen hier in der gedenkstätte
des kz flossenbürg ein eigenes
theaterstück gegen hass und
antisemitismus aufführen
so wollen sie ein zeichen setzen da fügt
sich gleich nach dem journal für und
wider an die zdf wahl duelle
thema heute geduldet oder willkommen wie
geht integration saskia esken spd
vorsitz und joachim herrmann bayerischer
innenminister csu werben für die
politischen parteien rezepte ihrer
parteien angetrieben und herausgefordert
durch fragen von schack und ella
banerjee und daniel putzen und nun noch
nachrichten aus der wirtschaft
die deutsche bahn hat weiter mit den
folgen der pandemie zu kämpfen im ersten
halbjahr verzeichnete der konzern einen
nettoverlust von mehr als 1,4 milliarden
euro seit april aber zieht die nachfrage
im fern- und güterverkehr wieder kräftig
an
schon für das kommende jahr rechnet die
deutsche bahn wieder mit schwarzen
zahlen
allerdings seien auch die schäden durch
die flutkatastrophe in höhe von rund 1,3
milliarden euro zu bewältigen
der bundesgerichtshof hat ein urteil zu
hassreden auf facebook gefällt demnach
muss das soziale netzwerk seine nutzer
informieren wenn deren seiten gesperrt
oder einzelne beiträge gelöscht werden
das grundrecht auf freie
meinungsäusserung decke auch beiträge
gegen migranten die von facebook als
rassistisch eingestuft und gelöscht
worden waren
dies muss laut bgh von facebook wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden
mit dem heutigen tag hat die menschheit
alle natürlichen ressourcen verbraucht
die sämtliche ökosysteme der erde
innerhalb eines jahres erneuern können
nach berechnungen von experten kommt der
sogenannte ehrt überlastung tag damit
immer früher im jahr vor 20 jahren lag
er noch im september eine zentrale größe
des ökologischen fußabdrucks ist der
ausstoß von co2 durch menschliche
aktivitäten würde allein dieser um die
hälfte reduziert so die
umweltorganisation wwf würde sich der
erst überlastung tag um rund 90 tage
verzögern
an der türkischen mittelmeerküste sind
bei waldbränden in der region antalya
mindestens drei menschen ums leben
gekommen mehr als 180 wurden verletzt
mehrere dörfer mussten evakuiert werden
die feuerwehren kämpfen gegen über 50
waldbrände von denen 36 unter kontrolle
sein sollen betroffen ist vor allem die
umgebung der küstenstadt manavgat auch
ein hotel nahe des urlaubsortes
boardroom wurde evakuiert die türkischen
behörden ermitteln wegen des verdachts
der brandstiftung
anfang der 80er jahre des letzten
jahrhunderts als noch völlig
unterschätzt
sprudelnde datenquellen und gierige
datenkraken damit anfingen uns alle mit
ihren computern zu verdrahten da kamen
in hamburg ein paar interessante leute
zusammen
schräge vögel geniale visionäre und
spielerisch veranlagte genies sie hatten
riesenspaß beim surfen auf der digitalen
welle die die welt verändern würde
und mit der sie sich auskannten wie
sonst kaum jemand im land
und dann war da noch die mission die
innen todernst war dafür sorgen dass es
in dieser revolution transparent und
demokratisch zugeht
das ist erstmal vor allem chaotisch
zuging war methode und wurde
namensbestandteil bei ihrem chaos
computer club eine dokumentation erzählt
seine turbulente geschichte carsten
behrendt stellt sie vor
ein neuer sound anfang der 80er rechner
setzen daten in töne um verbinden
plötzlich kontinente konzerne und
computer kids es beginnt das zeitalter
der hacker ein hacker ist ein mensch der
sich nicht nur von der oberfläche
anmachen lässt sondern versucht gerade
beim umgang mit techniken herauszufinden
was man sonst noch mitmachen kann
kreativer schöpferischer umgang mit
techniken liebevoll und unterhaltsam
erzählt der dokumentarfilm alles ist
eins außer der 0
die geschichte des chaos computer clubs
und die ihres gründers bau holland
datenschutz pionier und visionär
ich bin sehr bewundernswert war holland
waren typ der sich komplett eingesetzt
hat für eine sache eben
informationsfreiheit chaos computer club
sicherheit von daten und gegen
überwachung und so weiter andererseits
waren chaos typ schwer zu erreichen
unschwer zu greifen meiner mama hier war
dann war man dafür hat nur 50 jahre alt
geworden ist jetzt schon über 20 jahre
tot und wir fanden das ist absolut an
der zeit dem den mann zu würdigen seine
gedanken noch mal hoch zur tu wat txt
hieß der gründungsaufruf 1981 es gab
noch kein world wide web aber schon
lücken beim datenschutz beim
bildschirmtext btx ranking zum beispiel
der ccc brachte die besten hacker
freigeister ausgerechnet in einem
biederen deutschen vereinen zusammen
einige gingen über grenzen razzia nach
dem eindringen ins netz der nasa andere
hacker verkauften daten an den kgb club
ist hat einzelne mitglieder da kann man
keine kontrolle darüber haben
endlich ist aber teil der hacker ethik
lassen das definitiv nicht tun sollten
um geld zu verdienen um sich zu
bereichern oder am anderen menschen
schaden zuzufügen
danach hieß es dort aber tue nichts
böses mehr und mehr wird der klub zum
gefragten lotsen im neuland internet
kritiker von gesichtserkennung
bundestrojaner corona waren app was
würde wohl der gründungsvater heute
sagen zu unserem digitalisierten alltag
mit google facebook und co er kommt von
der technikseite doch waren bastler
typen hat immer gesagt der mensch muss
die maschine beherrschen und nicht
umgekehrt aber das geht in einer rasanz
im moment ich glaube das hat die ihn vor
allen dingen schockiert ich glaube er
wäre selber nicht mehr hinterhergekommen
die technik zu beherrschen
trotz aller technik liebe war der mann
mit der latzhose ein verfechter von
realen treffen alle an einem tisch ein
wunsch heutzutage so frappierend aktuell
und diese unmittelbare erfahrung wie es
wichtig und diesen ganzen virtuellen
track den sollen sich einige mal
abschminken
tja war nix mit abschminken der
virtuelle dreck ist die zukunft
tatsächlich das war es von uns wir
würden uns gerne für morgen wieder
verabreden 22 uhr ist ja freitag und um
0.45 meldet sich heute noch morgen in
der früh nazan guckte mir mit unserem
heute-journal update
[Musik]
ein guter abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein neues tief nähert sich
hier unter uns war von den britischen
inseln her und dieses tief ist verbunden
mit einem regengebiet über den alpen und
das macht sich dann am nachmittag vor
allem im süden deutschlands dann
bemerkbar mit starkregen und hagel in
verbindung mit gewittern sturmböen sind
inklusive schauen wir in die kommende
nacht und da gibt es ganz im norden
regen dazu kräftigem südwestwind als im
strombereich sonst lockert es im osten
und im süden auf und die sterne zeigen
sich bei tiefsten temperaturen von neun
grad nach westen hin und 15 grad in
schleswig-holstein 14 im südosten
ja und morgen erst einmal viel sonne
auch im süden deutschlands schauer gibt
es vor allem dann im norden zum
nachmittag wird es dann heftiger es
brodelt in der wetterküche aus den alpen
heraus wachsen dann kräftige gewitter
teils mit starkregen und hagel und auch
sturmböen dazwischen aber größtenteils
trocken und längere zeit sonnenschein
mit temperaturen bis 29 grad im süden
deutschlands und 20 grad in
schleswig-holstein die nächsten tage
am samstag gibt es vor allem im süden
teils kräftige gewitter das geht in
dauerregen über und vor allem in der
nacht auf sonntag temperaturen bis 26
grad im norden aber ebenfalls schaut
ziemlich unbeständig der tag ja und am
sonntag im süden dann teils ergiebiger
unwetterartiger regen der über längere
zeit anhält und größere regenmengen
bringt es wird insgesamt kühler 15 bis
23 grad am sonntag damit ein schöner amt